so why is it the data modeling in time
series fit together I'm going to try to
explain a little bit why so wake up here
are some interesting facts right well
I'm just going to establish my use why I
want to talk about this so the Internet
of Things is very interesting new
development it's kinda like it's almost
getting to be like a cloud buzzword now
item T was that I owe to you yes it is
and but I think it's pretty realized
whatever we define as regardless of what
buzzword it is whatever some analysts as
your gazillion dollar bargained for
it still comes down to one thing we're
catching keys to the internet really
quickly um you guys know what that thing
is up there it's right here that's the
net you just when I said that in Europe
we were like there was done that's a net
right
Google just bought nest for three
billion dollars now do you think Google
is in there a board meeting in there
McMahon you know we got this cool
driving car self-driving car great
search engine Google Apps that's cool we
need a thermostat now that is it what
they said it and I have like one in my
house to you yeah dude
do a good knows we're here we need that
data - they bought they bought three
billion dollars of what the f you're
doing yours creepy eyes it knows when
I'm there
it knows what I need he knows a
temperature no Google wants that
information air
say I did this it was really fun trading
I change the temperature of my house
it's currently 64 degrees in my house 1
how cool is that
and then that's that's what this is it's
Internet of Things now did I ever
mention once and when I talk about
that's the Internet of Things look but
it's a cool product it's a cool thing is
moving fast CES January refrigerators
talking here net telling your grocery
story ground up these are all just
things in future right and your car now
Ellen talks with sink so all these
devices are going to be talking so 15
billion devices estimate about forty
billion devices by 2020 that's a lot of
mouths to feed and that all that means
pretty much one thing this all has to go
in a database somewhere so let's talk
about what that is and it's almost
always going to be time series theater
temporal data here's something that
happened at this time the sander is a
great home for that and it wasn't really
designed for that initially but why can
standard for time series and then I'm
going to use this as a data modeling
launching point so as you saw my last
talk one slide proved it all and if
you're not a Cassandra user you can
prove it to yourself but Cassandra
scales that's good thing for you IOT
because there's going to be a lot of
apparently it's resilient which means it
is going to be online all the time and
it's going to deal with all the crap
that I throw at it it's great day
tomorrow
aha let's talk about that that's going
to be a big part of this but then beyond
that and this is the kind of a secret
sauce a commander of wide time series
data is so good is this efficient
storage model now the efficient storage
model as a programmer I really don't
care too much about right that's not
something I'm going to concern myself
with as I'm writing code
but I want you to understand what's
going on so when you're writing code and
you're looking at the data model to
understand what's going on under the
scene because let's face it what about
that I mean that this is the power with
what Cassandra could do so let's get
let's start out with the data model
example but I like examples good old
weather station and classic right this
is a classic time series temperature
over time so I have a weather station
here I'm putting that data into a into a
Cassandra ring and I'm going to display
it out in you know whatever format is Rd
grabs whatever so over the over the
whole day I graph all the different data
points great right so that's a that's an
easy one so how do you do what do you
start with Cassandra date alone data
modeling is a little different in
Cassandra because what we're doing
instead of taking the data and then
building models we're taking our
application and building the model so
I'm going to start out at the top with
what with my application going to need
for a query how much the application is
going to ask for this data I'm going to
graph this data on that on my website
what are those queries look like so the
first thing is I want to get your my
needed queries I want to get all my data
for one weather station okay I want to
get all the data for a single date in
time and I want to get data for a range
of date and times so all very similar
around the single weather station ID
weather station itself but a little
different I want a single date time I
want to get a range so how do i model
that so by data model support these it's
pretty simple I'm going to store data
per weather station that's my first
requirement my second requirement are
going to store in time series order
first event - the last of it
so what does that look like so I'm going
to create a table my create tables
pretty simple I have a weather station
ID which is just a text I use text
because it's here's actual value down
here it has some letters in it event
time which is a timestamp so this is
when it actually took the reading off
the weather station and then a
temperature in text now the primary key
is the interesting part here this is
what makes the data model rich and I'm
going to show you why it makes a
difference in a minute but this primary
key is an important piece of your cable
creation because what you're specifying
here is the uniqueness that partition
partition is here's all my data that I
would order in a certain way and then
our codomain together so much like how a
relational database has a primary key
this is d2 combined these two values are
unique same thing but what if this is
also doing is changing the way I store
my data I'll explain that so here's the
inserts look familiar right insert into
and I have 1 minute 2 minute 3 minute 4
minutes so every minute is collecting
data it puts a time in our temperature
in there boom Bob's your uncle good to
go so whenever I do a select weather
station ID and event time and
temperature from temperature my weather
station ID equals is whatever it's 1 2 3
4 ABCD I got a table that's exactly what
I was hoping that's what I want now if
you look at the order of that data again
I specified in the primary key before
that so the order was I want the first
thing that happened to the last going
back to this the event time is that
second part of the primary key the first
part sets up the partition the partition
is this weather station ID every element
in that partition will be ordered by
event time that's how I would describe
that to you so yes these two are unique
weather station IDs sets of partition
event times is the order that I'm
want that partitioning so whenever I do
a select off of this I get everything in
order without having to sort it in
memory good so what happens on the
storage I remember I told you I teased
you on that a little bit the storage
engine is the cool part of the story now
this is the part where as a programmer
you may depart and say long I'm good
with this I'm moving on I'm going to
write my code and ship it because it's
an agile thing and I got to do a demo
day tomorrow but let's look and see what
really happens I think the most
interesting part what's really happening
on the storage engine is this it
actually lines up that partition in a
single storage row now partition which
is specified by one two three four ABCD
is actually the beginning of a five it's
a file header and then every record in a
row sequentially on the disk are the
elements in that partition so what does
this get you well first of all it's
merged it's sorted and it's stored
sequentially on the disk
okay what does that get you when I start
adding data it just depends into the end
of that record that's great so
everything is still in order because
it's merged sorted in sequential this is
great for storing data but what's the
point why are we doing the point is
whenever I do something like this now
this is my this is my query where I'm
going to ask for that range of time
again keep in mind that that was one of
my application requirements is that what
I worry my dear I want to be able to
grab a range of time in this case I
wanted to grab it from one minute to the
four minute not very exciting time
period but that's what I want this is
called a slice very or range query if
you notice that it's the greater than or
equal to less than or equal to this sets
up these boundaries what does this mean
based on how I store the
first of all to get a single seek on the
disk unfortunately Al's right next door
telling you why this suck if you were to
be over there in here at the same time
you're freaked but that's cool
but you would hear him say well here's
the problem you're going to be running
into disk problems I'm going to tell you
yes you're going to run into disk
presence trust me but the way to get
around some of those issues is to
minimize the amount of seeks you do on
disk a seek on a disk Hertz because
let's look at everything in your
computer you know the CPU is in
nanoseconds memory is in micro or even
the a no seconds now but what's the disk
do spinning is just seconds that's like
orders of magnitude slower then we
haven't really fixed that problem sort I
mean we got we knew how new disk
technologies that are now available but
we still look at most most discouraged
systems in production right now are
speeding rust and they're measured in
milliseconds if you're using a SATA disk
7200 rpm SATA disk
you're looking at 10 milliseconds of
seat time attention to that hey my query
just turned into a 10 millisecond query
just based on that one thing and if I'm
chasing milliseconds that's going to
hurt okay so getting more less than less
than that one seek are you getting I'm
sorry less than one seek you can do that
but getting a less seeks is a good thing
so that single seek on disk that's what
I want I want to put the disc ad right
at the beginning of my data and because
what I'm trying to do here is get this
range I'm going to grab all this data
right here and I whatever I ask
Cassandra to get it it'll move the disk
there and sweep across the head and puts
it right back into a CTL table for me
programmer sees this they like this so
this is what makes that data model
really efficient
because it's stored on the disk when you
do a seek to that data it's really fast
it's very efficient you know when I read
Oracle the game was all about ions right
because why
everything's random all the Iowas random
on a world on my sea floor any
relational database do you have a DB
file and it randomly reads and writes to
the file so you better have a lot of I
us because that means you can do love
seats and maneuvers around Cassandra
doesn't do that Cassandra writes out
those SS tables one time once it never
does a random right after yes if you if
you like if you are in the right
temperature that's a different aim level
right now we're disorder because I've
specified the data model is I only want
order by by date I can specify an order
by in his query but that's going to have
to get sorted in memory my data model
said I need to do a date slice if I
wanted to do temperature I could change
the data model around a bit there but we
were fall when I for just a second for
the opportunity for in Oracle what you
do is you create an index on that and
you never cover the query so that your
temperatures would already be sorted yes
you have to go to this but again one one
sequin we
the cluster so all the data together
well you'd use a group by or you can
order by but if you create an index on a
second field inside Oracle it's not
going to order it'll only make it more
accessible so when you run the query
plan optimizer
it will find the data faster but it's
still not sorted on this and it still
has to do a random read on disk your
solution X's or sorted is you can do a
cover permits also is very about it but
the data is it's my point the data isn't
well you don't touch today do you read
it right and that's you're going to read
it out of the index but when you want
that data you're going to do random read
a lot because you're going to be putting
these all done this data model similar
ones out of the Oracle and you will
limit out real fast and mainly because
you run out items sequential operations
are going to be faster a larger dataset
a larger bigger the dataset you pop I
have one other reason this is going to
be faster as well and that's because
you're going to distribute that many
queries so let's hold off on the
questions for a minute let me move on to
the next topic and maybe that'll answer
some of these questions but it's not
just about this one thing there's a lot
more to this I got more I got more
secrets so what about some additional
help on the storage engine so let me
show you what a weed with the read path
looks like and Cassandra in a nutshell
when a client asks for digging it it
goes to the key cache the key cache is
like hey I have this that first part of
my primary key where is that on the dips
I want to know where that is on the disk
if the key cache does it hit you get
through one data file hit you do one
seek you're done because your total seek
time is going to be the disk latency
times the numbers right we want to
minimize that and we could measure all
this in Cassano budget there is a tool
called CF histograms which I did a talk
about Google my name and you could cycle
that's my talk but I did talk about this
thing called CF histograms you can watch
every single read see how many Peaks it
takes the news this is a very important
tuning technique if you're trying to get
the low millisecond on every query and I
did that many time 500 microseconds 95th
percentile is very doable if you do this
right so the next place is a bloom
filter I talked about that my last talk
bloom filters are just a probabilistic
function and all they do is they say
where the data is not so again we're
trying to find out where the data isn't
if you have thousand tables to look at
I'd really like to narrow that down to a
couple if I can
so the bloom filter is yet another way
to get that so those two things in
conjunction will help get us closer to
that minimum number of seeks but that's
not always going to work out because in
cases where maybe that row of data on my
weather data is spanning over two or
three columns families or SS tables I'm
still going to do a lot of seats so the
key to the speed in Kassandra based on
that on that particular read model now
like what how the reeds work in Sandra
here's the keys to speed and this is
actually this is important point number
one the first part of the primary key
that first part the weather station ID
gives you location that's going to put
you on a single server and I'm going to
explain how that works in a second but
that's going to put you on a single
server so if you have a thousand node
cluster that first part would put you on
one of those servers in that
Buster it will not be a random seek the
second part that partition key will get
you closer to the SSD and you get right
you want to minimize that seek you want
to get into that file as soon as you can
you want to minimize and then third
thing which I'm putting up here just for
brevity but we don't we won't cover as
much I do a lot of performance tuning
type talks but the other thing is how
fast you can find that data in the SS
table if you have a three gig file you
can use indexes to find that data
immediately so once you do is seek you
go to where the data is instead of
having a move that diskette across the
disk so there is a new feature as a 2.0
that will help you get to that data
faster this is actually there for time
series data and in those cases where I
might have three files on the file
system that could have potentially have
my data I want to minimize how much
seats I have on the disk so those same
query um I have this I want I'm looking
for data in between 1 and 4 I know
there's a bug in my code I forgot to put
an equal filter I get pointed out off
the shark route but here's three files
that it could potentially be in now this
min/max hint what we do is when we
create those files now we create an
index an index built on top of that file
that says hey here's the minimum maximum
values for this for this primary key
that your app that you've set up in your
data model and you can use that later so
how does that use so the minimum event
time here is the index shows that it was
a march 27th to 31st this one was April
1st to 4th and this was April 5th to the
ninth that's the event time so if I look
at my range over here when I ask that
question is like hey I want that I would
like a slice of that data please cut me
off a piece of that pie I have three
choices now for 2.0 which means I'm
going to have to do 3 seeks to see
finite data just make sure that I got
right well with this index hint now I'm
like well that data fits in here
this is the file one signal time series
data really can take advantage of this
there are other data models it's not
just for time series data that it works
for but this right here is how you get
to that class file fast this is how I do
time series data models in less than a
millisecond net mean a peyote you know
when I'm messing around with my nest by
the way nest uses Cassandra I want to
make sure I'm changing the temperature
of my house and pissing off my wife
really fast I don't wanna wait so I'm
gonna change a temperature really quick
funny story about this little video our
co-founder Matt filed he has a nest and
he had a roommate Mike Blauman who runs
apps in her team and when Matt was on
the road at night he'd jack up the
temperature Mike could wake up sweating
us I'm here what's going on the
thermometer or the thermostats broken so
what did he do he called support hey
this thing's broken it's like oh man
that's terrible so they're all trying to
diagnose as they're running all these
things on they're trying to figure it
out they they got back to him on email I
think we found a bug here apply this
patch you know do all this stuff and
finally found out that Matt was the one
turning up the temperature randomly the
guys at nest found out it wasn't pretty
but anyway just keep in mind you may get
busted eventually fun so now I can't do
it anymore
so whenever I go to nest and now they're
like oh say hi to match for us you me
just do all that extra work so I don't
real quick I want to go through some
ingestion models right now that about
getting that data there because this is
the next question I would get um if
you're if you're if you're at the point
where you have a database that you do
millions rights per seconds
you gotta have an application they could
do millions all right
second you know this is not a trivial
problem so one of the things that I like
to point out is some of the methods you
can get that in there because this is a
dictum this is a new game right you're
talking about internet things you to get
a lot of data together so when I hear so
much about right now in mana since I
talked to this after that cop-killers
project at Lincoln graduated it grew up
in a big world of interest Apache as
talking on the project is based on Scala
cool queueing system it is big based of
basically the same type of paradigm that
Cassandra's horizontal scale yeah more
delicate more scale lots of people using
this now and it's a really cool project
but I see it in conjunction with the
food pools storm is the other one storm
is a processing framework so if you're
taking it a lot of stuff you know
refrigerators all over the world tell
you what temperature's is decided with
refrigerant going through Kafka making
sure that that gets once and only ones
delivering storm will then roll it up
and do different things as idea she's
got a lot of data coming what are you
gonna do with it
you need a database that can scale up
Cassandra seemed to be the place people
have another one is one of my projects
of flu I was recently at the Hadoop
survey which is kind of funny for
example personal and um one of the guys
in my talk was Jonathan Shay who was the
original author flew and as I'm talking
about flume I see this guy like smiling
in the back I used to work on this
project so it was kind of cool seeing
that back back in old school this is an
old project that it's fused about four
or five years old and it was originally
built for congestive logs I use it for
bringing in syslog events but it's a
very simple program you create a source
with a listener like syslog HTTP there's
a channel which is like a bus and then
the sync which picks up those events off
the channel and then you can do
transforms what I did is I built a
system that basically took in HTTP
events from our f5 load balancers and it
parsed out the entire
log string and then created 90 different
inserts based on that one web hit so I
created this massive like web amplifier
right and it was the only thing I could
I was trying to put it into an Oracle
database he failed and then I just ran
out of money
really I tried to do it and the only
thing that really could scale up was
exadata and I didn't like spending two
million dollars of this one little blog
processing thing so I started using
Cassandra it was when I first started
and that was on point seven and it just
worked so I noticed that this thing is
producing tons of data I couldn't do
anything with it
the only other choices I could dump it
into like s3 you know it doesn't mean
anything I needed that data in
milliseconds so Cassandra countries so
let's talk about that data with speed
and this is going to move us into a
different dated modeling topic so if
you're going to do a million writes per
second do the math it and insert every
millisecond or microsecond microsecond
that's fast I don't know about you but I
don't know a lot of applications could
deal with that too much you got to work
as a team if you're going to do is
microseconds right everyone's got a
kitchen you put that on one single
server that is going to be the best
microsecond reverse of that thing's
gonna fit so there's other promise
collisions these are real problems if
you're in time series data collisions or
an issue
I did a talk at ING this is the Big Bang
and they're pretty public they're doing
financial transactions using Cassander
they're also very public about the fact
that there
collisions and how they manage they'll
be doing a really cool talk at our
summit so you know this is a this is a
problem the dealers right so what we how
do we manage that much data flying in at
the speed of mil microsecond so the
first thing is primary key place isn't
that no displacement and I'm going to
teach you how that works because I think
you need to know that primaries our case
this is how David it gets distributed
but it's also how you can do a lot of
things and how your data model really
depends on making that right also the
rate of partitioning how your data can
spread around that's a part of the
standard and then we also have a
specialty attack called a time uniting
at time of your ID is a great tool for
avoiding collisions with time since data
let's talk about what happens with our
weather stations I got a lot of weather
stations to feed so let's quickly go
into the replication story of Cassandra
and how that this is your data model so
the primary key that first part of the
primary key that I told you about that
is the important piece of figuring out
what server belongs to so how do we do
that so we have this really basic data
month on our primary key is the first
name of people which is really a poor
primary key but for our limited data
model it'll work so we have Jim Carroll
Johnny and Susie that's our data points
what we do in Cassandra with that
primary key is we hash it md5 or murder
it's a writ that is a consistent hashing
operation so that if you put in the same
string you'll get the same under twenty
bit number up awesome and this is how
many technologies work if you look at
memcache back
that far back that's how I got data
distributed in a reliable way it was
using md5 it would hatch it and then
throw it out into a reliable way so all
these keys are hashed now how does that
deal how does that do with Cassandra in
this regard and this is what I'm talking
about the data locality like where is
that data in relation to the physical
layout of your server how's it finding
so we have a four node cluster here node
a b c and d and each node will store a
range of data a range of tokens so we
take that big 128 bit number which has a
name I don't remember like a septa bike
or something and we're going to break it
into quarters so this one this is one
quarter of the range on a 1/4 a range of
be one quarter range on C and one
quarter on D each one of those nodes
analysis I'm primarily responsible for a
quarter of the range of that 120 bit
number meaning that when a one of these
is hashed I will see if it fits inside
my range and then I'll hope and no one
else will take it so I take Jim's number
hey it magically fits that 5e goes in
between 4 and 8 awesome so now C is
responsible for Jim's data Carol she
goes to node D Johnny goes to know de
now because md5 is somewhat random and
of your mathematician I got grilled by a
PhD in mathematics about other exclusion
and it's not really random okay but it's
pretty random and it's going to
randomize the placement of that data
around so as I did is getting set in
there it's randomizing so you're getting
good distribution but it's also going to
different nodes now what about the
replication each one of those nodes can
also say you know what because you're my
neighbor I'm going to hold your range
too so if I change my replication factor
that's all what that means is the nodes
become responsible for its own data and
then its neighbors data may be two
neighbors data which is a lot better
than my neighbor my neighbor would never
put anything in mine in his garage but
cassandra is more like working like a
tea
so whenever Carol which is the primary
responsibility is Dee well a and B also
say you know we'll hold that data for
you as well so asynchronously replicates
that David's not synchronous easy this
is right to the exact same time and
it'll send it to three nodes at the
exact same time now the one missing part
of this consistency which I'm not going
to cover in this particular talk but
consistency is how the client knows that
it got to those three nodes or just one
node you pick as a programmer you can
make a determination on consistency and
we just have to mr. consistency here are
you going to do the next doc you're just
dream cases oh yeah eventually you'll
eventually be consistent yes Chris Chris
house is out for Netflix he's a going to
do a talk and eventual consistency which
I think that will thank you
we're going to painful painful
consistency man this is not painful
right now this is good right now right
now so this is how data gets replicated
now how does that fit in with the rest
of it well whatever I'm writing that
million writes per second if I have a
very small cluster for nose that means
that there's a potential later that
means it's going to be a lot of writes
per second per node now that's because
each one of them holds a quarter so how
does that linear scaling story work if I
double the amount of nodes now each node
is only responsible for 1/4 1/4 or 1/2
of the quarters 1/8 I do
fracture math I have eleven year old so
I'm doing a lot of this now so each one
of them is doing an eighth of that if I
double it again then they are only doing
a 16 and so on 500 notes each one is
worth a hundred
of that set so as you add more notes
each they're just responsible for less
and less and less that's how it scales
up save up storage say with rights per
second you're also spreading it around
with this replication factor of three if
I have $1,000 plus worth it's still only
get a replicate to three nodes not to
one bird or something like that so
that's how you keep those notes and keep
those right spread out
so the time UUID last topic here so
timing UID is a timestamp to a
microsecond which is cool that gets it's
part of the way there plus a UUID now
that UID is added at the end in case you
have the exact same time Santa if you're
putting data in your database like that
then you want to make sure these valleys
are unique that's a time UID so what's
cool about these are also known as a
version one UUID which means it's
somewhat of a standard you can get
driver support for it in Python and Java
that's what I think they're sorta bull
meaning that if you present a bunch of
tiny new IDs they'll be in sorted order
and you could reverse it so when you
give it this it'll go I know what that
is that's this date so you can figure
out what day it is or what the timestamp
is based on this this really really
super small link over here is a webpage
to make that which I used on February 12
at 6:18 p.m. so here's my last example
where we use that time UID so again our
data Molins how we date a month if I'm
going to my needed queries I want to get
all trades and symbol for it and add a
crystals you're gonna love this example
by the way get a trade for a single date
time and then you get the last 10 trades
ah the last 10 trades that's kind of a
tricky one right how do I get the last
tip so my data model support that is I'm
going to store my data per symbol and
date I'm going to store it time series
in reverse order last two first and then
I'm going to make sure that every single
transaction is one
percent unique so even if through the
same microsecond so I'm going to start
buying some Netflix talked a lot of uh
actually sold a lot to so here's an
interesting thing with I'm going to
point out a couple of deals here on my
day tomorrow so these are just stock
ticker data typical type of stock ticker
data where it's coming in a rapid pace
so there could be potentially some
collision but what I've done here are my
primary key is a couple of things I've
put this symbol and date together as
that's the location that's my private
part first part of my primary key that's
going to give me my locality that's
going to mean that for every date which
is just like for one day and one symbol
it'll always go to the same group of
servers throughout the day so the next
day it'll move to a different group of
servers and then the trade is a time UID
so if I have the exact same at the exact
same second microsecond I'll still have
uniqueness to them and it'll be ordered
the next the last thing here is this
clustering order by this is a very fancy
way of saying I'd like to reverse the
order store it on disk by the trade
which is that tiny UID so that's kind of
an interesting plan so here's the order
thing I'm going to buy two thousand I
buy three hundred sell 450 and sell
three thousand okay so that's the order
that I did them in when I go to look for
that data
notice it's reverse this is the last
thing that happened at the top of the
list the first thing that happened is at
the bottom of the list so now I'm a
reverse order based on the trade details
or that trade time that UID gets parsed
and reversed but right now I can't even
tell you what times I'm sure it could so
what does this look like on the disk
though now that I've told you to reverse
sort this is when it gets really
interested because now what I did is
because I told it to reverse or and
merge now it actually does that on the
disk too so whenever I go look for that
data I'm going to say hey I want a limit
of three limit three cool
coolness in times what I'm saying when I
say limit 3 is I only want three things
returned but because I know I reversed
it I'm going to get just three items the
last three items the last three trades
that happen boy this data model is used
so many places for fraud detection for
user sentiment for identity tracking on
websites this is really a cool day
tomorrow so when I say limit 3 it's
going to go to the beginning of the list
I didn't have to all the way to the
other and then come back go to the
beginning a list from here to here and
you just bring those rows back very
efficient now I just have the last three
trades that have happened I think that
is a cool way to do things like I said
I've seen I've done personally done a
lot of these data models in production
using a reverse that clustering order by
with a limit to create really
interesting interactions with time
series because all those things flying
in as fast as they are you need to be
able to do that yeah is descending 7
house going down you're right
nope not enough answer test a shift
everything
well it's much shorter than memory first
so it's a memory operation and then that
file that the way that Cassandra writes
out is a sequential right so it will
write that file out there's a weekend
we're getting into likes of operations
things but later if there's two roads of
data it will do a compaction operation
as a normal background operation and
then burn short those in memory again
but that merge short memory it's a
hashmap will sort that properly so it's
not going to slow it down
order is independent of how fast it
means our data it's just the feature of
how that works yeah more questions
because I'm at the end of my slide so
there shouldn't be a lot of imbalance
unless you specifically put it well with
me5 you're not going to get into I mean
if you're using a stock rating
Netflix month is a volatile stock right
you would end up using the same
potential yes in those cases way what
and isn't knowing your data model if you
know that's a potential case here's a
great example is like if you're looking
at URLs all right can you say here give
me here's the row keys URL a day well
all day long that row is going to be the
hot spot there in that case what what
I've done is just put like modulus in
there or something else to make it more
unique and then how to consistent way of
managing that that's knowing your datum
um but knowing what you just found out
is pretty critical now you know oh if I
do that maybe that won't be so good
maybe I will have a hot spot I will just
be writing to the same note of the same
replica set over and over now what we
hope for in that like with the stock
trade example is there's a company
called circa that collects all stock
trades around world 2 million a second I
doubt you're going to find a hot spot in
that yeah you know Netflix stock may be
hot at one moment but there's still
zillion other things going on so it gets
washed out the noise it may cause a
little bit of a blip but with that many
rights per second going on in your
cluster that's not really a good
consideration now if I was only looking
at a select group of stocks and I knew
that one was going to weigh more than
the other okay that's a different game
so something you have to consider for
sure but if you look at the big picture
distribution of that won't be a problem
I think another variation
the question concern is you're going to
end up with some wine rose right is that
a concern not really and the wide row
concept all right so that partition how
big can a partition be two billion cells
now that's that's great it sounds like a
lot but if I'm collecting like weather
station data every second it's not a
last you can do that's when you get into
to what or if I could just collect all
trades for one stock one symbol forever
then yeah two billion is going to get
eaten up pretty quick so that's when you
probably want to think about what am i
doing in my data model the reason I
added date that date in there let's go
back to this the reason I add a date in
there is to eliminate that problem now
that I know every single day will be a
new day for a new partition that will
help as many of that now do I think I'm
going to get two billion in a day I'm
saying though I won't the dis prevention
of this data model you would have
tension problem entities
the day changes but if you're looking
for limit Fritos if it's not going to
what's great about the stock market it's
one loaded forget all this time to
create that you table yeah I know and
that's the right maybe that's a
different consideration in here so and
that that day tomorrow I showed you with
the WebP is that actually had a how'd it
feel to sustain but what I did was you
know we just had a little bit of logic
in our system organize grab particles at
those off moments the chances that
somebody we did everything in ddd the
chances and everything everybody being
at work at midnight VT we pretty high so
there wasn't even an entrance for us to
and absolutely but we just had enough
code in there to deal with that
situation and our it was pretty
efficient out we didn't really have any
problems with that but something to
consider right you're going to you're
going to be transitioning to in our new
partition if you are designing a data
model bug this is then you still have to
think about all the edge cases before
you
a lot of times yes and get to know data
modeling I put up here the planet
Cassandra oh there's my animation again
because I'm so proud of it huh Lana
Cassandra has a lot of cool interviews
those five-minute interviews like use
cases but also white papers things like
that so I would hope you wouldn't have
to reinvent a nice round wheel again
you know people like myself I've done
thousands of data models
I just and now I'm kind of like the
horse whisperer I just walk up you know
because I were to get all the reasons we
do things and you'll get to that point
too I've worked with teams now for a
long time um I work with Christmas's
team quite a bit nobody's you know no
one is really like digging too deep
anymore because they get all the points
and then they're just building the data
models and sometimes you just it's like
relational when I first started doing
SQL I'm like what is this this is crazy
talk but then after a while is is doing
in it you know in my sleep
it's the same way but what I don't have
to do now is think about how I'm going
to scale this thing once it's in
production how I'm gonna keep it online
how big my Oracle it's gonna be so there
all right we're out of time it's 11
o'clock thank you very much